come and given for the afternoon session
our first speaker will be honest Venson
from epfl and he'll be talking about
okay thank you very much so yeah so this
is joint work with Morgan felt mom is
now at the Open University in Israel and
liquids inclusion who is at the ATH so
we I will talk about secretary problems
we will try to device an algorithm then
we see why it fails and this will lead
us natural to this other problem where
we can do something very nice I think so
that's why it's two points the secondary
problems we will try you will see what
we're what's the difficulty and then we
come to a natural other problem which we
also call online contentious solution
schemes which is similar to the offline
content resolution schemes you might
have seen for some other function
maximum maximization
so before yeah so before starting with
our greens let's you know most of you
probably know the secretary burns but
let's look at the classic sector program
and here you know maybe
classic your problem like all of us have
been looking for jobs okay so you came
here yourself so here what's the goal so
you know maybe your model is you have
applied for end jobs and your goal is to
select the best out of these offers with
high as possible probability that's what
I see the goal is to devise a strategy
that makes you to accept the best
possible job offer okay and what do you
know well you know M so you know the
number of jobs you applied for and now
the rules of the game is that you you
don't expect universities to like all
collide against you so they offer should
arrive in a random order or no no first
but you should get the decisions in a
random order and then then you only know
the value of the offer when it arrives
okay
the salary start off package and so on
and then a little bit strange okay so
you have to accept or reject the
military that's the rules of the game so
yeah and you cannot change your decision
so that's what makes it vertically
interesting maybe not so practical
okay so yeah that's nuts again so here's
example see they arrive in a random
order so you get maybe T you're Berlin
is
it's a good place but it's the first one
so you know reject maybe Princeton Wow
second place is also yeah we can be at
the walmart you're surprised I didn't
even apply Microsoft Research 7.2 well
if it's the second to last maybe it
might be accept so yeah a couple of
years ago I gave this talk about some
reason all right so now what's the best
strategy seriously what's the best party
you know this well I see I see
yeah so all these problems so they
arriving around the world but we don't
really know what to expect right so so
the natural thing to do is to split
basically the prom into two stages so
you have a sample phase where you sample
what you could what you can expect to
get okay what's my status in the market
and then we have a selection phase where
we used information we see in the sample
phase to make some decision all right so
so in a selected sample face even before
seeing whatever goes around
I will pre reject okay so before seeing
whatever the value I get here I reject
and then I just observe what is the
distribution so in particularly in the
standard secretary prom I will recommend
the best offer I got in a sample phase
and then in the selection phase remember
I'm interested in selecting the best
possible offer so it doesn't make sense
to select anything below that values I
will select the first offer that has
value above seven okay so maybe eight
and this is a reasonable strategy
because if you say that the sample 50%
of the element then I will succeed we
poked at least one for right second best
is here we probably 1/2 and the best is
here we put the 1/2 and if the best is
here in the second bus is there I will
always succeed and if you're careful and
you sample one Ori and do a careful
analysis you can see that the
probability of success is one already
it's all resolved by Duncan is 66 days
and this is tight so it's there's not
much to do but later on we will see more
general variants and then we will still
have a sample phase and then we will
call the element that is better than
what we saw in a sample phase to call
them improving elements okay so the 8
here is an improving element in any
single sector you just select the first
improving a lot so that that's old it's
a nice program but it's solved but
recently there was increased interest in
you can generalize this right I think
the motivation by climbable bias and all
that came from mekin is design I think
ok so you can think about this you know
instead of only selling one Goods you
can sell a set of goods but you have
some capacity constraints and customers
arrive randomly one by one and and you
have to decide yourself to this customer
at all or not on on the spot ok so so
with that motivation if I want to sell
one good to customers arriving like it
to my shop you know it's a natural thing
to say that I have K I have a capacity
of kaykai radio players in my shop ok so
I am really to sell up to K guys and
that's what the most basic extension
they study so what if I can choose K out
of em secretaries of k out of n offers
and here you know we change the goal a
little bit from devising a strategy that
makes us to select the best possible
offer to a strategy that we select us
high weight as possible so we will
correspond we will compare yourself to
the optimum way it see if we can select
- if we can select two secretaries here
the optimum solution will be a
him plus 2030s I would like to recover a
lot fraction of 30 for the photo op of
this part all right okay good yeah yeah
please put that I'm not an expert in
history so point out yes okay so good
but now now you could guess okay so I
generalize the problem so you can stack
a out of any set of one out of them does
it make the problem easier harder what
would be your gut feeling or you if you
think about it might be better if it's
no gut feeling so it's easier right
because if i only can select one i
better not make any mistakes but if we
can select up to k customers sometimes i
can make mistakes and sometimes out so
here you can prove that you get one
roughly one minus one over square root
of K okay so when K grows it gets easier
so it's more so this also very well
understood but let me give you one you
know a shoe with maybe my favorite open
question is concrete where we don't know
the answer okay so that's that's this
kind of Netflix problem so you are a
server maybe Netflix and your customers
on the verge says so that's potential
clients they they give bids that they
want to access your streaming service
but if you accept their bid you have to
guarantee at least one unit of capacity
a path from the server of one unit to
them okay so maybe this guy arrives he
says I'm willing to pay for to have
access to the server you say okay let me
give you access next guy arrives they
run a random Oregon 7 ok let me also
give access to you notice that I can
change the path that they give to the
red guy as long as I always have a one
unit guaranteed for him it's not that I
fixed he doesn't care as long as he has
access to the server
okay let's accept the blue guy the green
guy comes
well let me reject him the purple guy
can you see that I have no choice
because here is a mean cut of size 2
when I already accepted these two guys
so the purple guy I cannot accept I
don't have a capacity my network ok it's
a mean cut of size to orange guy maybe
except I shouldn't have done though but
because there's this guy and now again
there's a cut of size free and I accept
the free guys I cannot accept it
so here it's open to find any constant
competitive area it's a pretty nice
question competitive here you know it's
opted offline over the expected value of
your argument here the expectation is
over the random order and also
potentially randomness of your wheel I
think I flipped this left one but I
think it's pretty clear if C is greater
than 1
ok so it's - you know stations the k out
of n and this one and and this this is
if if you know your control of my
session this is a gamma it ok so this is
a special case of a micro so so the you
know sation that generates them all is
its the secretary problem where the
elements that we want to except to form
an independent set in a Metroid so to
previously stated wear the uniform
Aykroyd and the gammaroid the whole pier
is that defining this problem you can
capture many settings like the two
examples I gave you but at the same time
matrix have a lot of structure right
matrix capture exactly when a simple
greedy arguing works so the hope is
basically that you got some sweet spot
between structure and generality to
still be able to do something useful
so the question is okay so what I'm a
try so if you don't know that it's
unfortunate but but but the hope is you
know that then you can think about the
spanning trees or a cyclic graph the
remaining part of the talk so whenever I
talk about matrix think that you we are
trying to solve the maximum weight
spanning trees where the edges arrive on
line so my ground set will be the set of
edges and independent set is just a
subset of edges that are are cyclic for
a cyclic graph you know crisco's
algorithm is the greedy algorithm and
why critical works is exactly explained
by the properties of a matrix so let me
quickly so maybe if you don't know
matters maybe after a couple of these
talks you will know mattress let me s
quickly so so matron has two axioms its
downward closed so if if I have a set
independent set and I drop some elements
then it's still independent and the
second axiom is that if have two
independent sets and one in the plants
that is bigger than other then a must be
an element in a big one that I can add
to the smaller in a cyclic graph that's
true right if I have a graph with fewer
components that are 1 there must be an
edge so that they can decrease the
number of components of that so another
famous example that could be useful to
think about in this talk is the linear
Metroid you just have a bunch of vectors
a subset of the vectors are independent
if they are linearly independent and the
reason is because towards the end of the
talk I will talk about spam and rank and
that exactly coincides with standard
definitions so the span of vectors is
just a linear subspace and the rank is
in on dimension
okay but anyway if you never saw this
think about the graphic Metroid so the
roadmap of the talk is that I want to
talk about some known results see what's
known then we'll try to devise an
algorithm we get stuck which leads us to
online contention resolution schemes and
then donate them basically said we have
some kinda target up you're unable to
analyze which i think is a clean
algorithm but we have tried and failed
but it could be good for you
okay so what's known okay so there's a
lot of known on special cases so don't
ask me so graphic Maitre you can get a
2e ok here it's assumed that you know
the whole graph in advance yeah first
first of my yeah don't ask me to define
this measure so it's a 8 3 e K times e
case pair of sparsely numerators okay
but what you could observe here is that
there is a lot of constants ok except
for this one ok but a lot of constants
for many types of matrix and and and in
fact the open conjecture here is more
general denies that the first in the
talk it should there should be a
constant for anime trader ok and this I
should say that they were brave because
they made a conductor before the results
so so they were very very good intuition
if it's correct maybe it's wrong the
connector yeah otherwise yeah otherwise
that conjecture is true because
otherwise you calculate the optimal
solution and only accept those a month I
mean if you
but actually it's interesting because by
out bidwells you can see that that
conjecture is equivalent to having a
distribution over the weights of the
elements if you could solve that case
you could solve the one so if you know
some distribution but the distribution
is correlated anyway you just write down
some Alti and okay so even something
stronger could be true that is that if I
look at matrix I could still get a 1
over e competitive algorithm so we don't
know if this problem is harder than
single sector problem and for the profit
inequality dr. not be true so you could
generalize the standard profit
inequality that was a result by climb
barian but that's there so so they show
that the profit inequality single profit
inequality gets you one half and if I
look at the more much more general case
matter I still get one half but here we
don't know so what do we know so there
is a clean log round competitive area
okay Rakesh and Shaggy birthday they
have a squared log rank and more recent
like it's just a log log grant
competitive area so these are not as
simple so so so so the hidden cost is
very big ok 2 to 5 to 2 power 32 so you
need pretty big rank
so what but so so what we could do is
still we have a I had acquired because
it's not simple but it's little smaller
constant ok which is a simpler limb so
actually but to be fair those arguments
have I think the reason why they're
complicated and our how large constant
is finest and things correctly these
arguments give you that with high
probability I will recover 1 over log
log rank of the fraction of optimum
where's our album only does so in the
expectation
so then the heating consists this big
because if you want the with high
probability result you want
concentration so that that's my
intuition why the hidden constants so
big all right so so so let's start easy
so let's start by devising this which I
hope we will be able to do then we start
to try to get down to log log and we
will get into trouble okay
so warmup Lord grant competitive
algorithm and this really follows by two
standard tricks okay so first I hope to
be able to convince you that the on wait
the problem is easy if all elements have
the same weight I ask we accept okay so
greedy I'll going gets me optimal think
about if I only have to accept k out of
n sectors they all have the same value
take the K first ones yeah but this
works for any Michael it
okay so unweight the prom is pretty easy
but now I can reduce down wait oh yeah
reduce the weight that you done wait the
case by losing a long-run factor okay
why well I can ask you know do geometric
rule things I put all that amount with
weight between one and two in the first
bucket between two and four in the
second bucket between rank over two and
rank in the last bucket okay so I claim
that I only need log rank many buckets
why is this you never need to care about
elements that have weight less than a
maximum weight over the rank because the
amount of such elements you could pick
the total weight of these armors would
be at most of weight of the heaviest
element so here to do this pocketing I
need to have an estimate of the highest
weight element in my microd that's not a
problem to get look that's simple to get
by sampling okay so here I use something
and then after I did is pocketing I just
run the unweighted are going on one
bucket because all of them especially
look the same with in effect of two
okay so that gives me in expectation
October maybe to log round
that's the log-rank i-i'm the only place
where use the sampling phase is to
calculate what's the weight of the
heaviest element and the rank of my
micro if I don't know that up front so
this didn't use much of Metroid's and in
fact you can get similar guarantees in
much more general settings okay so
that's what's a nice soft this year by
bounce time so you showed a log rank log
and competitive algorithm for any down
close problem so if you have only the
first axiom okay so here for example you
could have MP complete prawns like
independent set but you can still get
the logger you assume that you have an
Oracle that can solve this problem so
it's not for normal time but it can be
this good and that's pretty tight quite
tight because they also shown the paper
that in them this you know setting you
cannot do button log n over log log n so
I'll go live to do better using a micro
structure because these arguments they
base it
well they don't use to make the
structure okay let's try so then a good
starting point is to start with
algorithm that we did for a singer
secretary problem and let's try to run
that on a Metroid and let's see what
goes wrong okay
so naive generalize and we will do that
by looking at the graphic maker so let
me remember we want to find a maximum
weight a cyclic graph okay so now you've
attempt okay
so first up your sample by including
each element we point to one half
yes that's before well one house instead
of one away then this here the dashed
line is just the maximum independent set
of the sample and remember that in a
single secretary
we only accepted we accept that the
first secretary was better than the
sample how can we translate that to a
graphic kay so when should we accept an
element so for example two
it would never be part of a maximum
weight independent set right because
it's spanned by higher weight elements
so - I know
I don't you I do not take it's not
improving it's this guy would never be
part of a maximal weight forest so
improving if and only if not spam by
heavier entities so I don't take that
guy for well that's better than free so
let's take him seven it's better than
whatever spans him so let's take him -
it's improving right because it's the
one is smaller
take him 11 oh I should have taken him
but I can't okay because my greedy
algorithm selected four and seven
because they were improving and I'm
gonna love and come I'm unhappy okay but
that's the simplest you know I said you
didn't do right you sample you take all
the improving outlets so here we would
get value 13 which is I guess pretty
good so why does this fail because it
fails so it's not so easy okay so we
call this the Hat so you have one very
valuable element on the bottom connected
by this unimportant element but you
don't of course you don't know you have
this guy okay so what so this is a tower
infinite tower yeah so now what happens
you sample the opt value is basically
only this edge do you sample case maybe
this is your sample now we start
accepting proving elements maybe this
guy's improving there's nothing before
this guy's improving this guy's
improving and since the tower is so huge
before you even see this edge if it
exists you will have accepted this some
configuration like this so this prevents
you from accepting this edge whenever it
arrives okay so greedy algorithm
so this Pam and you can make it more
complicated which we will see you can we
call it a recursive Hut
you can hang some hats on this edges
later on so that's bad okay so what goes
wrong so let's take a step back okay so
we run with sample and then we run the
greedy algorithm okay so which elements
can we be safe that we will pick okay so
here here I only drew the improving
elements after the sample I don't know
them but they are there somewhere okay
so which guys am I guarantee that my
algorithm will pick okay no no comment
so so if I have a cycle right I don't
know which one my argument will leave
out but that these elements that I'm not
taking part of a cycle of improving
elements or that are not spam by other
improving elements those I'm sure my
arguing will pick any greedy algorithm
that just adds improving elements we'll
pick these guys right no okay I call
them good ok so the goal of problem is
to select improving elements because opt
elements are always improving I'm
improving element that does not form a
cycle with other improving element is
good ok so here this guy is good that's
good that's good
but the red guys are not good because
they form a cycle and awhile we might
miss out on picking one of these guys
but for sure it will pick the green
elements
yes so are we and will always select the
good elements no matter the rival order
and haft of course has the problem that
since the tower was infinite we always
have the good guy
forming a cycle with some other
improving elements so profitable edge is
never good
that was our problem these guys always
good we pulled the one half that these
guys never did okay so this but we still
want to analyze our algorithm with
respect to good our elements so we would
like all elements to be good with some
good probability good with good
probability and the way we want to do
that is to decompose the problem into
independent problems so that each
element is good we can sir Provost okay
so let me see give you an example how we
do it here okay so yes the guys that
form these paths they're good we put the
1/2 this guy's never good we need to
protect him from these other improving
Alan's right how do you protect things
in a micro well you can just induce on
whatever you need to predict remove the
other elements so for sure if I don't
have the other elements this guy will be
good they will not spawn him and then I
contract to get out of my traitor okay
so here I contract the dis edge to get
data mated here
we will see why I contract so now this
is always good he's he's alone there's
nobody that can span him in this
subproblem these guys are still good we
point to one house because they are not
good only when the other guy is also
improving okay you're with me there's a
single game okay so now the reason that
I contracted is that they have this
still this statement solutions in I can
solve this instance completely
independently but their union still
forms a solution to originate with okay
so for example if I run this show on
this problem and on this problem I took
this element and a red guys here you can
just lift it up to the original problem
and I seen the panel so that's why I
contracted so this was able to decompose
this problem into two independent
problems where we can just run the
trivial algorithm and be happy yeah so
very good so there are there are two
problems with this here it works
perfectly well but the first problem is
that we don't know the distribution of
improving elements this they just
arrived right we cannot before seeing
anything we don't know which ones will
be improving so you make the sector pond
we can only ask right the distribution
of improving elements over 50% of random
elements so we don't get the whole
distribution we just get the
distribution of a 50% of talent and this
is a problem that I don't know how to
solve okay so this the current times are
not clean and they don't give what I
think is the right take composition but
the second problem is that even if you
know the distribution of improving yards
why she should set the composition
always exists okay that's not clear
leader right why should I be able to
decompose my palm so that all elements
become good so we wanted a composition
that each improving element is good with
constant probability and that that's the
second question just show that this is
possible brought us to what we call
online contention of solution schemes
so I will answer this question on that
that has a clean proof okay so resetting
remember that each element has a
probability of being improving X sub e I
call it active now it turns out that if
you do the calculations the the vector
of the probabilities is actually
feasible in the micro polytope so it's a
in a spanning tree case it will just be
a fractional spanning tree it's you can
be composed into convex the composition
of spanning trees so this is pretty nice
it is says that if I have a trivial
algorithm at least fractional it works
okay the problem is that they appear
together okay so here's an example this
guy comes with two first two first
two-thirds one-third one-third one-third
and one so you see that this can be
decomposed into two spanning trees now I
make an assumption which is necessary
you don't need this strong assumption
but you need some assumption so I say
that the distribution of active elements
is a product distribution so probability
one appears is in the plant from E to
appearance on that's not true for
improving elements but in this setting I
will make it
but on the other hand now I also assume
that elements arrive in adversarial
order this is not so bad the assumption
actually because all the secretarial
arguments they can have adversarial
order after the sample stage they only
use the random arrival to sample and
then they can make the decisions in
adversarial order
so here it's example so this is you can
think of a priori information so here
second guy comes the coin flip
we'll probably one third he's active -
first he is not active if he's not
active I cannot pick him this guy comes
you flip a coin is active I can pick him
this guy comes he's active I can I
cannot pick him I can make a decision
and so on okay so I can only pick active
edges and I only see if they're active
when they arrive and my goal is to
divide the strategies like that pick
each edge with good probability so our
fear IAM is that there is an online
algorithm such that for each element we
selectively put one fourth condition on
it being active so they exist in
particularly we show that you can
decompose the method so that each
element is good we put the one fourth
that's what I will show you so if you
need some further motivation so this is
very related to contention with solution
schemes if you know that D but this does
it online
okay because it with respect to any
ordering but if you need some further
motivation so I'm not that familiar with
this but so you can think of this being
selection with a prior information so
you can think of an element and edge you
know some distribution of its values or
its bids if you want to think about game
theory and then you put the threshold so
that this element of C is equal to XE
okay so this this corresponds to for
example to the profit inequalities we
get the worse constant we get the
constant four instead of two but we get
a much stronger oil we get a strong
adversary so dear adversary only knows
what arguing knows put in the next
element our adversary can know
everything because we only show you that
we will select elements if they're good
and there is no nothing the adversity
can do to prevent arguing for selecting
good elements because you know they were
the ones that are not spanned by
anything and there was also an open
question if you can do an oblivious
pricing mechanism it's basically to post
prices and serve people as long as you
can and that that this answer so you can
get that with a fact losing effect of
four
so one thing here is that you have to
change the matrix structure to get this
to hold you have to do this
decomposition so that's a little bit
unfortunate but I think that's necessary
so you cannot just do posted pricing
with original Metroid that's a little
bit technical and they saw some other
stochastic probing application most of
all I think it's a nice question okay so
so let's see if we can do this so
remember we want to we want to decompose
a problem into independent problems so
that each element is good with constant
probability so I claim that there is
only one way of doing this then we have
to analyze that it works but there is
only one our unit can do this okay okay
so the only algorithm well we have a mic
right here with all its elements
consider the arguing elements that are
not good this means that they're spanned
by active elements let's say we put DC
open nine nine
I just made it into some constant here
so I put it very high so they're very
likely that they cannot be picked
because there's an under active elements
that span these are the problematic
elements this is this exactly
corresponds to this guy he's the
probability that his band is like 0.9999
okay so these guys we need really need
to protect because you know they are
spammed by elements so these guys need
to be protected and we know which guys
need to be protected so that's all set
us so now we decompose it into we look
at the remaining Maitre you get by
inducing this element and the contractor
might I don't know does the contractor
made for it okay and then you occurs
maybe there is some other guys that
still need protection and you need to
select them recursively so that's the if
you think about this the only hour you
can devise for this problem but we need
to work prove that it works so in in in
the generalized hat this will correspond
to so here I have some green edge than
blue edges and on the blue edges I hang
another hat okay see you so each element
appears before the 1/2 let's say so here
for sure we need to protect the green
guy because of the blue guys but we also
need to protect the blue guys because of
the
red guys okay so first s we select will
be that we need to protect the red and
the blue they're all very likely to be
found
okay so we will need to protect them and
the red guys will go somewhere else and
then at the second step we will need to
still protect the green guy okay so we
will remove the blue guys and then we
then we stop this will correspond to
that we select the green and blue edges
here to protect and then we selected the
green guy here and then we are done but
for this to work the only thing we need
to prove is that we don't need to
protect all the elements okay because it
would be problematic if the set s will
be the whole set then you just continue
forever it's important that make some
progress and if you could prove that we
can make progress we are done so in
order to prove that we make progress
button we need to prove is that not all
our elements are likely to be spawned in
a mate right so we have a fractional
metric point each element appears we put
X E so what we need to prove is that if
that holds not all elements are likely
to be spammed
because not all elements are spam we
produce 0.99 receptors of probiotic
elements is a strict subset so why is
this true well yeah so the rank of the
span elements for this intuition the
rank of the span elements is at most a
number of active elements expect the
number of active elements is one half
times sum of XE which is a north rank of
a tool so here I use that I only take an
element which I pretend that an element
is active we'd only probably XE / to's I
scale it down by a factor to expect the
number of active elements is at most
rank over two but if I only span rank
over two of the Metroid there must be
some elements outside that are nuts
bound that's informal area or argument
okay let's check the math okay
so yes let P sub e denote the
probability spanned by active elements
remember I will not now scaled down to
be active report the XC / - so I have a
sum over X C times P okay so this is
basically expectation of the X values of
the span of the active element with the
expectation over active elements the sum
of X values in the span this now what is
the x value of the span of a remember
that X is in the micro polytope so this
is at most the rank of the span okay X
was a face both luciene in metropolitan
but what's the rank of the span of a set
think about your vectors right
just taking a span of a set of vectors
doesn't increase the rank so this is the
rank of a the rank of a couple of
vectors it's most in number vectors and
I would expect the number of number of
guys since each guy pairs we put XC over
to this as one half times now your PE
and one half not all the PS can be
greater than one-half so our set has not
all elements can be bigger than simple
I took shipping 99 to make more
intuitive to get to 1/4 you put P to be
one-half then you have 1/2 to the you
scale it down we put one out you know
1/2 that is not spend so I
how much time do I have
oh okay so we will do so this was
special proof so this is almost a
complete work so there's one issue okay
so when we contract an element's you
remember the the the the example I did
right so I had an edge and then I had
all this the tower and then I contracted
this element that might increase the
probability for these guys to be spawned
okay when I contract the matter that
might change the probabilities of the
elements that I didn't contract that's
an additional difficulty okay so what's
the solution
when you contract and if you need to fix
some guy just add him to your service
iteratively so now we have to prove
something stronger not only that the set
s that you start the wid is a strict
subset you need to prove that the set s
you obtain by iteratively adding the new
dangerous element is also strict subset
okay so why should this and then you do
that whatever you did before okay so so
claim set s of robotic arm is still a
strict subset so why is that you know
suppose you have the the set s that you
want to contract is a vector space we
have like three basis vectors each guy
was span we pulled the 0.99 that you
always contract him shouldn't really
change the back to space right he was
already if you add him as a basis what
does it matter if he already spawned yes
and so if I have a vector space if the
if a basis vectors span we've 0.999 I
don't need to add them to get the same
but then I just get the same space so
most times I just get the same space
okay big slack in the previous proof
contracting arm at the span we produce
April 99 does not really change the
probability for elements so the the
proof is just that you get plus because
the probability that you need to add the
basis guy is just 1 minus 0.99 so you
get plus 0.01 the rank of your set
okay
then you do exactly the same thing okay
you can also assume that your sum of X
is for my basis in the micro it and then
you then you get the answer okay so
there are some technicalities but not
much okay so this last in a quote yeah
sorry but the first argument doesn't
depend on X to be yeah it does right
this stuff here
you take the first equality at your
mouth yeah yes yeah yeah this is the
only place are you studies in the
metropolitan good also if you really
follow what I was doing so far I'd never
used anything about the independence of
the distribution there is only
expectations where do I used in the
panas of my distribution because here I
have to say that the probability that
you're spanned is the same probability
as if you condition on being active so
if I condition on you being active your
probability to be span should not go up
a lot so that's the only place will be
used and the information about the
distribution all right summer if results
so knowing disputes of improving us you
can get a decomposition that gives you
one over for quite some applications but
for the major sector one we can only
estimate this ratio improve my house
make it more messy okay so what would be
my candidate arguing for major sector
problem I mean I think it works I don't
know what we try to prove we fail okay
so here we decompose a micro based on
x12 exam
what would happen if I just give you 50%
of the elements but they gave you the
probabilities of their dumb being
improving and then I asked the composite
based on that so yeah this is like if
you if you have all the weights take
look at the probability that an element
is improving right you can take 50% of
the elements check if it's improving
there's some probability P
you look at the sample then you see you
have now split it into two samples on
the first sample you can occur at the
distribution of improving elements and
then you run it on the second sample but
the cleanest question that we have try
to think about is that even in this
simpler model I give you 50% randomly of
taxis can you done do it is it a good
decomposition for the remaining elements
so intuitively to work because the guys
that you need to protect they are not so
sensitive to remove a couple of guys up
here half of them if I remove half of
that is here this guy's still very
likely to be spawned so you would still
protect him so that's the intuition I
where I think it should work yeah so if
I if I give you the weights of all
elements of the microwave now can you
can calculate the probability of dumping
spam right bias checking over all
possible samples was the probability
that you're improving elements 50% of
the elements today drop yeah so yes so
you have X is equal to probability of
the sample e is improving with respect
to s okay now you cannot do that for the
whole set but you can start with Burt
just taking around on 50% of your
element and then calculate these X's
based on that one example then run the
decomposition based on that and then
just run the algorithm if my intuition
that this should work is because the
illness that you need really need to
protect they're not fragile they are
really likely to be spam
they are not in a punt so that's also so
but I still think it works because the
only place where you use some
independence is not in this proof it's
the one the probability of being spans
you not change dramatically if I assume
that you're improving so for example the
OP tournaments that they're improving is
independent you can do you can do that a
composition based on distribution that
this will be improving elements because
that decomposition works the question is
if it's good for the elements because
yeah
that's probably yeah because that's a
little bit vague and as I said we were
not able to prove anything yet
but to concrete open plans that I like
is can you do fracture Maitre secretary
problem we don't know so here I mean
that instead of accepting or rejecting
an element just take a fraction of it
and at the end of the day you want to
recover a fractional well you want to
recover still a constant fraction of the
total weight the fractional the
fractional solution should be a constant
fraction of the optimal this should be
easier for example is trivial just take
each element before 1/2 and it's a
feasible solution but we don't know how
to do this and then done this the game
modes I talked about in the beginning
thank you choose my way if you were able
to get a fractional solution combined
with the online why does that not imply
a deterministic solution as well sorry
plug it into online contention
resolution and get a integral solution
yes very good question so the reason is
if we could do fractional secretary then
you could first calculate the fraction
for the first one how if you see or and
then build your decomposition on that
the problem is at the moment we need a
fractional solution for the whole space
and Danka
so that's exactly relates to in my
candidate so we it should be robust to
removing some elements but we are not
able to put no log it can may be but
here it's all or nothing
okay this time